what's the biggest screenwriting pitch
you've ever gone out on
and what happened yeah there was a pitch
that i had with my writing partner we
had a lot of pitches um
one solo i've been on that haven't been
like you know oh my god this is with
it's been with you know heads of
television or whatever but
i specifically remember one pitch we did
and
the head of the company was there the
whole strata of people
were there the assistant the vp and
we went on for way too long i mean it
was absurd how long the pitch was
they basically told us we saw the whole
movie
you know it was like a 20-minute pitch
and no one stopped us
and we were crazy enough to rather than
make it five minutes or oh and
you know and we walked out of there and
our manager said they're gonna
they're gonna buy this and blah blah it
was just like oh my god
and uh something happened where it
wasn't
it never materialized but um there was
another pitch it wasn't big but
the the guy made us wait
and he was late and then we're sitting
in the lobby and we see him
in the office and he sees us and he like
pulls the blinds and we're like i know
that's a good sign and i hadn't we had
been around and i hadn't had lunch and i
was like freaking out i was like i gotta
eat something so i went in their pantry
and i was like ripping open bags of
cookies and stuff
and oj i gotta get my blood sugar up you
know
and then he comes out hey and he walks
us into his room and we're like
okay he's back in our you know and we
sit down and
what do you got for me and we go well
here we go and we always would pitch
where um
my partner was like pt barnum you know
and i would fill in the blanks here and
there
we start to pitch and about 30 seconds
into it he's stopped oh
well stop stop stop stop he goes it's
it's it's crap because it's just i don't
believe any of it and we're like
he's joking you know of course he is
right he was serious and we both look at
each other mortified and we're like
wow that's never happened and then
he uh came around from the desk
you know and leaned on the desk and said
okay here's the thing
i got an idea from my nephew and he sent
me a 10-page email and now he's pitching
us and i've never had it where where
ever i mean all the pictures of my
entire life
so you never know but they always let
you finish i mean they'll interrupt you
but they'll let you finish the pitch he
cut us off
at the knees and then he pitched us he
twisted around and you think well okay
um maybe that'll be our idea and he says
what do you think
and we're like i don't know what to
think i think we got to get out of here
you know so we both left and um
he rode the elevator down with us oh wow
he said you need validation i said i was
hoping it was from you but yeah
i need it for the 18 to park
you know because you were late 45
minutes with your other meeting
uh cookies were great in the pantry but
that doesn't you know
so uh he said all right you know go off
and blah blah
we never saw him again but so you never
know pitching is a really mixed bag
and i've also been on a pitch at a
big production company with the heads of
television and they
i mean it was out of body experience i
mean i was almost sitting like
who is this guy i mean i was sitting
like next to myself watching it
because i and they were late which many
times
you know they'll make you wait you're
not just like the doctor's office you're
like it was for 11 30.
you're like i know but it's 12. and
i'm sorry i'm sorry you know would you
like some water no i'd like scotch
please
excuse me and then you begin
and that was on you know sometimes you
know you're just on
and you can see it and the questions
that they ask
are at the end which is great they don't
interrupt you in the middle
and then your train of thought you're
like uh you know and you're
you know then the questions were just um
what city do you see this happening they
weren't like i didn't get the part about
the thing and you're like oh no you know
because you practice your pitch
backwards forwards before you go and
it's it's a lot of it's improv too
you know what i mean and you have to
leave those spaces open for them to go
could it be a thing
yeah yeah that's great i love that oh my
gosh
you've made it that much better yeah
yeah
but you have to leave it open for it to
go you know
certain ways and i left and they were
like thank you very much
and i called my manager and she was like
oh my god i wish i could have been there
and seen that i said it was
it was high it was it was a great high
walking out of there
now they didn't buy it but i
pitched at a professional level where
that door is completely open
so it's not like who that yeah you know
what i mean
so you never know you're just talking
about pitching it's a mixed bag but you
have to
it really helps to have a writing
partner you know when you when you both
go in
except the one guy we wanted to like
flip his desk over and go what and break
the windows and say
you know he turned the tables on us for
sure
so when you leave a situation like the
one that you just mentioned not not the
one where you've you've had an
outer body experience almost but the bad
one the bad one
yeah how are you regrouping like how are
you
saying well that time we went back to
our handler you know
and said oh my gosh and this is like
ridiculous we had such good
pitches during the day and that one was
just off
from another planet i don't know what
happened there and
um you know you don't let it rattle you
too much you got to move on and that's
not the end-all be-all
it was just a freaky deaky situation
you know you don't want all of them to
be like that
sure i remember another pitch um the
person was like you know
almost falling asleep and that's not
good either
but you're like at least you could hide
that you know i know you don't like it
but
and then the minute that we finished
you know she got up and said well thank
you very much for coming in you're like
this
is was just a waste of time everybody
you know
maybe you could tell like they can you
know you can read and another one's like
oh
my uh there's one at a studio there were
like diapers around the office so i my
nanny usually has the kid but i had to
there's like a little we're like yeah
don't be distracted we're only trying to
you know pitch for our lives here you
know
it's always like you never know
when you come off of one that was like
magical
sure how soon are you finding out
they're they're telling you it's a pass
right away
uh usually they get back to your agent
or manager
right you know shortly thereafter it's
not like weeks after no and then they
say yeah you know we
we really like uh what was they're gonna
buy it i mean out of
sometimes they buy it in the room you
know it happens but
but more importantly about that is that
you you show that you have ideas
that you that you you know you have
cohesive ideas that can actually like
we're saying
what makes something a tv show well you
can pitch something they go
yeah that's like the stuff we do you
know and so it's on that level
of like oh it's convoluted it's all over
the place
it's not even a good pitch you know so
many holes in it that's what you don't
want
so you've done your homework before you
ever get there and then that keeps the
door open
and then of course um you send a thank
you card which i always
say you know handwritten thank you card
after that uh not an email to those
people that you met with
because they'll get it a week later and
they'll even if they pass they go
oh mark yeah you know what he because
they're busy with a million other
pitches
you know 100 a week or whatever you know
and it's like oh yeah
i really like mark you know that one
pitch was was close
and the closer you get each time it's a
little closer and maybe
the close only is here for a while and
sometimes
the close is actually become something
you know
so even though you didn't get it's like
the one that got away
yeah it sounds like you still are left
with a feeling of
i almost got there rather than one where
it almost you feel cheap
yes when you leave like it's a bad date
yeah and just like
there was going to be violence i mean
when the guy was like he came out from
around the desk and goes it's ah yeah
he's yelling at us we're like
we looked at each other like he's he's
got to be joking and he wasn't you know
it's one of those weird situations
oh yeah whoo he's serious okay
this train wreck just went off is even
worse and now we're left with a
i don't know what we're left with you
know but
what gets you into the pitch is your
project so they have to read something
right so they read something they go oh
wow this is a great pilot do you have
anything else i get this other idea i've
got two other ideas
come on in you know it's the round
robins when you try to there
you get those fans of your writing you
want that
at a lot of different places so that
they can be that door's open what
else do you have that's why i say for
writers that you must have a lot of
material you know
a solid body of work that you've worked
on
that's at a professional level because
that script will get you in that company
and then they'll listen to your pitch
and then they'll say
we passed but they won't say in the room
they pass but
they tell your handler and they say what
else does mark have
that's similar well he's got another
thing oh we'll send it right over so
there's your next chance now
who knows if it'll sell or not but you
keep that you can see how you can burn
out stuff quickly too
but you need that constant
um uh wheel you know turning of creating
material
you know not just the one script because
the one script could be a one-off where
they go this is fantastic
you got anything else that you've
written well i'm working on something
and i'll be done in six months
well we'll see ya i won't be here i'll
be fired i'm the executive you know
but whoever's here maybe will answer
your call or won't and
you know so you have to keep that
constant and it would take two or three
scripts i think
whether tv or features you know and if
you have a little accolade like whoa i
almost placed in a contest or something
oh great you know
rather than i'm just another writer here
with the script
please buy it you know
did you get any of those you said you
got them through an agent because you
had a handler
yeah agent and a manager well at that
time just a manager
you